la commanderie a fait nuit blanche ce
week end cette année l'événement et et
pluridisciplinaire mêlant dans ce
sciences et arts visuels objectifs de
l'événement faire découvrir à la
diversité de la création contemporaine
au programme quatre artistes étaient
présents pour présenter leurs oeuvres
c'est le cas de l'installation babel
composé de quinze mille tonnes la
thématique babel donc fait référence
fait écho surtout à toutes les
situations et crise qu'on traverse
actuellement et qui vont assez sensible
un sujet là j'ai voulu vraiment mettre
en lumière le fait qu'aujourd'hui on
peut tous parler la même langue et très
rapidement de puisse comprendre
pendant la soirée la compagnie le grand
jeter a donné deux représentations de
son spectacle réplique un spectacle qui
casse le traditionnel mur avec le public
c'est l'idée de la pièce de jouer avec
le public de s'échanger d'avoir des
regards de l'inviter à la danse et du
coup de briser un peu ce quatrième mur
qui peut parfois rire sur scène
[Musique]
e
l'événement s'est déroulé à la
commanderie un lieu riche en histoire
qui a inspiré les artistes et émerveillé
les visiteurs c'est l'amour comment nous
dansons dans cet endroit historique avec
notre structure
ce site décor notre spectacle mais nous
nous fondons aussi dans le décor il ya
des choses auxquelles on rentre dans le
pack de deux valeurs mais il ya des
artistes là où ils les prennent ils les
mettent en valeur pour transmettre des
messages derrière et vraiment c'est très
étonnant c'est magnifique
j'ai vu les acrobaties j'ai vu lanta
j'ai vu l'intérieur de la commanderie
j'ai vu un chat carton là bas au total
cinq projets artistiques étaient
présentés dans les différents lieux de
la commanderie
[Musique]